هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر ان لجنه التنسيق ومراقبه وقت
اطلاق النار في السودان بحثت في جده تقرير
عن الانتهاكات كذلك اليه ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى السودانيين في مؤتمر صحفيا
نواشنطن تمتلك ادوات للتعامل مع انتهاكات
وقف اطلاق النار ولن تتردد في استخدامها
في جده ممثلوا لجنه التنسيق ومراقبه وقف
اطلاق النار برئاسه السفير جود فري شاركوا
في مناقشات بشان ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه وقد اجروا مباحثات مع نظرائهم
السعوديين بشان ادعاءات عن حدوث انتهاكات
لوقف اطلاق النار اللجنه تطلع على تلك
التقارير وتواصل المراقبه وعندما نرصد
انتهاكات لوقف اطلاق النار لدينا القدره
على الاعلان عن حدوثها واجراء اتصالات مع
طرفي الصراع في السودان